[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه
وستون
ايراني
روسيا توسيطر على سوليدار وعينها على
بخموتك
تترقب دفعه دبابات بريطانيه لتعزيز قواتها
تايوان
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
ترامب يطالب وزاره العدل بالمعامله بالمثل
في قضيه وثائق بايدن لكن الاختلافات
جوهريه تبدا من المبلغ
[موسيقى]
20 22 بدات الاحتجاجات في ايران وتواصلت
الى الان بطش النظامي والقمع لم يفلحاه
فكان الحل بسلسله اعدامات بحق المتظاهرين
الامر الذي اثار سخطا وانتقادات دوليه
الامم المتحده وصفت تلك الاعدامات بسلاح
لتخويف المواطنين ومعاقبه افراد يشاركون
في الاحتجاجات والقضاء على اي معارضه
الثاني لحقوق الانسان فولكر تورك اعتبر ان
استخدام اجراءات جنائيه لمعاقبه الشعب على
ممارسه حققه الاساسيه مثل التظاهرات او
تنظيم تلك التظاهرات يرقى الى عمليات قتل
بموافقه الدوله وتاتي الادانه الامميه في
وقت يواجه فيه النظام الايراني ضغوطا
دوليه عديده لوقف اعدام المحتاجين حيث
استدعت عده دول اوروبيه السفير الايرانيه
او القائم باعماله بادانه تلك القعده
في نهايه هذا الاسبوع تم اعدام شخصين مره
اخرى لمجرد مشاركتهما في الاحتجاجات
اسمهما محمد مهدي كرامي ومحمد حسيني
النظام الذي يقتل شبابه لترهيب شعبه ليس
له مستقبل
الاعدامات حيث نقل موقع ايران انترناشونال
عن الناشط الاصلاحي والعضو السابق في
البرلمان الايراني حسين مرعشي انتقاده
للقضاء بسبب تسرعه في اعدام المتظاهرين
اكد مرعش لان القضاء لم يسمح للمتهمين
باختيار محامي عنهم او الدفاع عن انفسهم
حتى بدورها اعزازه منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه المخاوف بعد نشر قائمه تضم مئه
وتسعه متظاهرين معرضين لخطر الاعدام كل
هذه الاذنات والمخاوف والتظاهرات في ارجاء
البلاد لم تلقى صدا في اروقه السلطات
الايرانيه بل ان المرشد علي خامنهائي
اعتبر ان التعامل مع ما وصفها باعمال
الشغب يتم بطريقه عادله وان اصحاب المطالب
هم مجرد مثيره للشباب
حماده حماده
قرار امريكيه يوم
مختلف اوروبا
في ايران يبدو انها ستكون متواصله ولا
بريئه امل في المستقبل فالغضب وانعدام
الحل يزيدان من حده الاحتجاجات والمشاكل
الاقتصاديه في قلب الاحداث هذا ما خلص
اليه تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوستند الى قصص
واقعيه من حياه الايرانيين الذين يرزحون
تحت وطاه فشل اقتصادي وتحت قمعا للحريات
يتحدث عده ايرانيين لصحيفه عن شكواهم من
ارتفاع تكلفه الايجار في طهران وحتى ان
حلم امتلاك منزل صغير وسياره ولو كانت
مستعمله اصبح بعيدا الملل نقلت واشنطن
بوست عن مراقبين تاكيدهم ان الوضع
الاقتصادي المتدهور اججج للترابات وزاد
السخت بشكل اكبر منذر ربيع الماضي عندما
بدا التضخم يتزايد ونهارت العمله مقابل
الدولار مسجله ادنى مستوياتها سياسيه في
ديسمبر الاهم في التقرير ان قطع السلطات
للانترنت للسيطره على انتشار الاحتجاجات
اثر سلبا على احوال الاقتصاد حيث يعتمد
عليه نسبه كبيره من المواطنين في العمل
على سبيل المثال تطبيقات سيارات الاجره
والاعمال الحره الاخرى صرخات المواطنين
بحسب واشنطن بوست لم تلقى استجابه ويبدو
ان الحل الوحيد المتاح لديهم الان هو
محاوله الاطاحه بالحكومه بعد بعد من عدم
الامل في الاصلاح
نتابعه الان من لندن في هذا الموضوع مع
الخبير في الشؤون الاقتصاديه والماليه
باباك امام اهلا بك معنا الاستاذ باباك
ماذا تقول الارقام كيف اختلفت منذ بدء هذه
التظاهرات والاحتجاجات في سبتمبر حتى الان
عن مكان عليه الوضع من قبل
كويسين
الى الاسابيع الاربعه الاخيره كان هناك
خفض انخفاض 50 بالمئه بعمله بقيمه العمله
الايرانيه 50 بالمئه في الاسابيع الاربعه
فما من سبب يدعوا ان انه في الاسابيع
القادمه الاربعه القادمه
انخفاض اخر وبالتالي فان هذا يعني
المزيد من التضخم
في اثار سيكون هناك السنه الفارسيه
الجديده وهذا سيرفع التضخم وفي ابريل
سيكون على الحكومه ان تضع الحد الادنى
للاجور وسيكون
بين 20 الى 40 بالمئه وهذا امر اخر سيؤثر
على تضخم وفي مايو ايار سيكون هناك اسعار
الوقود سيتم تحديدها وبالتالي هذه كلها
عوامل ستؤثر وما احاول قوله ان التضخم
الان 60 بالمئه
وخلال اربعه الى سته اشهر ستكون 120%
اما في همم
الشمال
من 60 الى 120 بالمئه هنا نتحدث عن
هذين الجزئين المطلين على الخليج العربي
الفرنسيه بمقال امس
تحدثت عن انه النظام الايراني ساهم مؤخرا
في تعميق الازمه الاقتصاديه وزياده
الاسعار للتخفيف من حده الاحتجاجات
بالشارع الايراني اولا هل توافق هذه
النظريه وليست هذه الطريقه الانتقاميه اذا
صحت تعبير من المواطنين يمكن ان تكون صيفا
ذو حدين يعني ربما تخفف من حده نزول الناس
الى الشارع لكنها قد تؤجج ثوره جياع ضد
هذا النظام
ايران
الايراني اقتصاد ضخم لان تعداد السكان
ضخم جدا حتى في اوضاع اليسر يصعب اداره
هذا الاقتصاد الا ان هذا النظام على مدى
43 سنه لم يقم بشيء الا سوء الاداره فهو
مهتم بالموت والدمار والارهاب فهو نظام
عصابه وليس بنظام طبيعي شو ادارته الى
الاقتصاد هي السبب وبالتالي ليس لديهم ما
يكفي من المال
ليمول داعيهم وهمم يدفعوا اجورهم هذه
الفكره همم
خروج شعب الشارع هو لانه همم جوعها وليس
لديهم همم طعام كافي همم ولا يستطيعون
دفعه
همم تكاليف الطعام همم
هي كانت فعلا مطالبات بالحريه لكن الان
ستصبح المطالبه بالحقوق الاساسيه وهي
الخبز والطعام يعني النظام الايراني بكل
السنوات الماضيه كان يردد بانه العقوبات
الامريكيه والاوروبيه همم لم تؤثر علينا
نحن اقوياء لدينا اقتصاد قوي وكانت قادره
فعليا على بيعتها بطرق ملتويه اين عائدات
النفط هذا السؤال الذي يساله كل ايراني
يور
ابستحقه تماما هذا النظام
130 او 30 30
اكس بوكس
وهم يصدرون الثوره والحروب
ونسمع الى نقاشاتهم في هذه الايام يتحدثون
وانهم يعملون انه سيكون هناك صدام بين
الولايات المتحده
والصين في منتصف
2023 هم يعملون لمثل ان يحدث مثل هذه
الفوضى
يعملون حدوث الحرب كي يتمكنوا من البقاء
لفترات اطول شكرا جزيلا لوجودك معنا
الخبير الاقتصاديه والماليه من لندن
تحياتي اليك اهلا بكم من جديد وجه العاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان وبناء على ما رفعه
ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان باستمرار
الدعم الاضافيه
برنامج حساب المواطن لمده ثلاثه اشهر
اضافيه وحتى دفعت شهر مارس 2023 الى جانب
باستمرار الحته الجيلي في البرنامج وياتي
ذلك استمرارا للتوجيه الصادر في شهر يوليو
من عام 20 22 والذي تضمن تخصيص مبلغ 20
مليار ريال وكان صدر امر ملكي في يوليو من
العام الماضي بتخصيص مبلغ 8 مليارات رياله
كدعم مالين اضافيين للمستفيدين من برنامج
حساب المواطن لنهايه العام 2022
[موسيقى]
في الملف الاوكراني لا صوت يعلو فوق معركه
سوليدار المتنازع عليها بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه في ظل سعي موسكو الى
تحقيق اول انتصار كبير لها في الشرق كيف
اكدت ان القوات الاوكرانيه تواجه موجات
منها هجمات القوات الروسيه على بلده
سوليدار الصغيره الغنيه بالمنام فيما قالت
مخابرات غربيه ان القوات الروسيه ومجموعه
فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه سيطرت بالفعل على
البلده وان هدفها القادم وبموت سيطره
القوات الروسيه على سوليدار سيمنحها
الافضل في ظل قتلها للسيطره على مدينه
مخموت على بعد عده كيلومترات الى الجنوب
الغربي المخابرات البريطانيه رشحت ان
روسيا من خلال محورها في سوريا دار تسعى
الى تطبيق
من الشمال وتعطيل خطوط التواصل الاوكرانيه
وهو ما رصده مراسل على الارض رائد الاخبار
ما زال الجيش الروسي يحاصر او يطوق مدينه
باخمط من الناحيه الجنوبيه والشرقيه
وتطوق قوات فاجنر والقوات الشيشانيه كما
هي قوات لوغانسكي الشعبيه بلده سيلدار
المتاخمه لباخ موت من الناحيه الشماليه
وتدور هناك معارك ضاريه يعني معارك وحروب
في الشوارع قتال شوارع اذا صح التعبير بين
هذه القوات الخاصه والجيش الاوكراني الذي
ما زال صامدا ويحاول الجيش الروسي دفعه
للانسحاب من الناحيه الغربيه الاله
العسكريه الروسيه اا الثقيله تقصد
باستمرار المناطق الغربيه والطريق السريع
الذي يوصل امدادات عسكريه وبشريه الى
القوات المحاصره لذلك لا امدادات لهذه
القوات المحاصره بينما ما زالت القوات
الروسيه تقصف مناطق عديده منها نقطه اتصال
عبر
سبوتنكسار لينك حيث قطع الاتصال ما بين
القياده والمقاتلين على الجبهات
وفي ظل تسارع التقدم الروسي في الشرق
الاكرانيه يبقى الحل في الدعم الغربي
بالاسلحه لاوكرانيا بالتحديد انظمه الدفاع
الجوي لمواجهه الهجمات الروسيه المكثفه
بالمسيرات والتي تعتبر رخيصه الثمن نسبه
لانظمه مواجهتها صحيفه وسط جورنال نقلت عن
ممثلين عن اداره الرئيس ان البنتاجون
يواجهوا صعوبات في تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه
استطلاع وضرب نموذجيه للتصدي للمسيرات من
طراز باير الصحيفه في تقريرها اوضحت ان
حجمه العقد لتوريد المنظومات يبلغ حوالي
40 مليون دولار وهو ما لا يكفي للكميات
الكبيره التي تطلبها كافت بحسب التقرير
فان الولايات المتحده ستسلم اربع مجمعات
من باير الى اوكرانيا في موعد لا يتجاوز
منتصف هذا العام كما ذكر ان 10 انظمه اخرى
ستكون في نفس النوع من نفس تحت تصرف اكياف
بحلول نهايه العام الحالي
الحليف البريطاني دائما ما كان جاهزا
بالمعلومات الاستخباراتيه تدريب الجنود
وايضا الاسلحه يا طاهر هذه المره حاولت
لندن دفع الحلفاء الى تغيير طريقه هذا
الدعمه
دراستها لارسال عشر دبابات الى اوكرانيا
من طراز تشالنجر 2 لاول مره منذ اندلاع
الحرب وهي دبابات القتال الرئيس للجيش
البريطاني الخطوه بحسب المصادر هدفها دفع
الحلفاء الى ارسال دبابات قتاليه الامر
الذي تعهدت به فرنسا ايضا حيث ستزود
اوكرانيا بدبابات قتاليه مدرعه خفيفه من
طراز ام اكس 10 ار سي فيما لم تستبعد
المانيا ارسال دبابات من طراز ليوبار
اوكرانيا وهي مركبات قتاليه اثقل من
مركبات ماردن التي ارسلت بالفعل لاوكرانيا
ارسل نحو 40 منها بالفعل لكن في كل
الاحوال تبقى الحاجه بتاعه البريطانيه
اكثر الحاحا الان معروف عبد الحق
بريطانيا تدرس خياره منح الاوكرانيين 10
دبابات من نوع تشالنجر 2 وذلك ضمن خطه
تقودها الولايات المتحده تضم نحو 50 دوله
بتقديم دعم عسكري لاوكرانيا دبابه تشالنجر
2 هي دبابه القتال بريطانيه الصنع وهي
ثالث نسخه من نوعها بعد تشالنجر اي 30 1
دخلت هذه الدبابه الخدمه في الجيش
البريطاني عام
1994 وتوصف بانها من الدبابات التي لم
تدمر يوما على يد اعدائها واستخدمه
تشالنجر 2 من قبل بعثات وتمارين لحفظ
السلام لكن اول استخدام قتالي لها جاء في
مورس 2003 اثناء غزو العراق كما استخدمت
في البوسنه والهرسك وايضا
بريطانيا لم تتخذ بعد قرارا نهائيا بشان
ارسال الدبابات الى اوكرانيا ولكن في حال
قررت تجميدها فانها ستكون اول دوله ترسل
الدبابات غربيه الصنع لاوكرانيا وهو ما
يتوقع ان يترك تداعيات كبيره على الوضع
الميداني بين موسكو وكيم
تماما وسنناقش ابرز هذه التداعيات بعد
قليل مع ضيفنا ولكن نتابع الان من ما
قالته صحيفه تلغراف البريطانيه والتي نشرت
تقريرا يرصد كيف يمكن ان يؤدي تزويد
بريطانيا لاوكرانيا بدبابات تشالنج
تشالنجر 2 التي تحدثت عنها عروب قبل قليل
كيف يمكن لذلك ان يغير من وجه المعركه في
بين روسيا واوكرانيا التقرير رصد قوه
الدبابات في مواجهه نظيرتها الروسيه نظرا
لتزويدها بروح حمايه قويه تمكينها من
النجاه من الضربات المباشره من دبابات تي
72 روسيه قوه الدبابات تشالنجر في اصابه
ثمانيه اهداف مختلفه في الدقيقه الواحده
يمكنها من احداث ثغرات في خطوط الدفاع
الروسيه التي وصفها خبراء عسكريون
بريطانيون بالهشه وفقا لصحيفه تلغراف
التقرير اشار الى تعويله بريطانيا على ان
قوه الدبابات التي يرسلها الحلفاء او
سيرسلها الحلفاء لاو ستكون قادره على
تكوين قوه ردع كبيره للعدد الروسي امر
اخير اثار المخاوف بحسب تلجراف حيث يخشى
المسؤولون البريطانيون من ان الدبابات اذا
ارسلت لاوكرانيا واستحوذت عليها روسيا
فانها ستكشف اسرارا عسكريا خطيره عن قوه
تشالنجر 2
الدبابه البريطانيه تشالنجر 2
دبابه قتاليه مصممه لتنفيذ مهام هجوميه
دخلت الخدمه في الجيش البريطاني عام
1994 تم نشرها في البوسنه والهرسكوسوفو
والعراق
يمكنها اصابته ثمانيه اهداف مختلفه في
الدقيقه الواحده
تتميز بنظام الكتروني للتحكم بكثافه
النيران الجيش البريطاني قال ان ارسال عشر
دبابات تشالنجر 2 سيمثل تصعيدا كبيرا في
الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا
وينضم الينا من القاهره الاستاذ احمد
عليبه الباحث في وحده الدراسات الامنيه
والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك استاذ
احمد يعني مدى الدبابات التي ستزود بها
بريطانيا اوكرانيا هو اقل بالمدى من
منظومه منظومه الدفاع التي تمتلكها اصلا
اوكرانيا وبالتالي هل ستكون فعاله بالقتال
في الميدان بالشرق الاوكراني
انا في ظني انه اي سلاح من هذا النوع
سيدخل معركه بالتاكيد سيكون قيمه مضافه
للجانب الاوكراني سواء بالنسبه لتشالنج تو
او ايضا ما يتم دراسته حاليا فيما يتعلق
باسماء المانيا عن اعتراضها على ارسال
ايضا ليوبارد تو لانه همم بريطانيا في
الحقيقه ما عندهاش يعني كميه كبيره تقدر
تفصلها الى الجانب الاوكراني في حدود عشره
بالكتير هي بتمتلك حوالي 277 واحده
وبالتالي يعني هيكون رهان اكثر على الليو
بار تو لانه في حوالي يعني 2000 واحده
منها موجوده عندها 13 دوله وبولندا بتحاول
تضغط الحقيقه على المانيا ان هي توافق حتى
لو هتبعث الجزء اللي هو ترسل الجزء اللي
موجود عندها وبالتالي احنا بنتكلم هنا على
تنوع بالنسبه للمدفعيه بالاضافه الى
التنوع ايضا الخاص
التدريع المهم زي ما حضراتكم عرضتم في
التقرير الجزء الخاص بالبرادلي او بالام
اكس اي 10 ار سي دي يعني ايضا هتشكل اضافه
فيما يتعلق بهذا الجانب لكن فيما يتعلق
بمنظومات الدفاع انا باعتقد انه المساله
هنا هي تعويضيه لانه القوه الغربيه حتى
الان احنا بنتكلم على تسليح ارضي ميداني
وايضا منظومات دي فعلا لكن ما تقدرش ان هي
ترسل مقاتلات على سبيل المثال همم لانه
مستوى التسريح الغرب هنا هو مش بياخذ فقط
مساله انه انه يعني في كم او في متغير في
الميدان ممكن ان هو يحدثه ولكن ايضا
المعادله السياسيه يعني احنا وافقا لبرامج
الدعم الغربي همم بحلول الرابيه تقريبا
احنا بنتكلم على اكثر من 80 85% تستحيلاته
سيكون في اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان روسيا بتضع دفع اعتبارها بشكل
كبير جدا انه بدا يبقى الرسائل السياسيه
المتعلقه بهذا الامر اكثر من الرسائل
العسكريه ولا ننسى ايضا انه روسيا هي
الاخرى اذا كانت اوكرانيا بتحسن من
قدرتها العسكريه سواء الدفاعيه او
الهجوميه في روسيا ايضا بتحاول ان هي تدرس
يعني مساله انه يكون عندها بدائل ايضا
للتعامل مع ده وهنبدا نشوف معركه هجوم
وهجوم مضاد بعد ما كنا بنشوف هجوم ودفاع
يعني هو يعني اجبت في سياق همم وفي معرض
اجابتك على السؤال الاول عن بالتالي كيف
ومتى تقرر هذه الدول ان ااه تحدث همم يعني
من همم المساعدات او التي تقدمها على
الصعيد العسكري لانه في جانب سياسي ايضا
كما ذكرت همم وهنا اذهب الى النقطه
الثالثه حول المخاوف من سيطره روسيا عليها
وبالتالي اكتشاف بعض الاسرار العسكريه او
من سيطره جهات الثالثه على هذه الاسلحه
الثقيله همم وهذا قد يكون مخيفا احيانا
خاصه اذا كانت حركات متشدده
استاذ طاهر يعني انا لديه ملاحظه على هذه
المساله يعني خلال الفتره الماضيه كانت
تسليح اللي هو تسليح الافراد زي همم
المنظومات
الاستنجر او الجافل وده طبعا فرضته ضغوط
همم الحرب لانه اوكرانيا ما كانتش جاهزه
لها هذه الحرب فبالتالي ما كانش في همم
يعني جيش بكامل تعباته وبالتالي تم
الاضرار الى انه يتم تصليح المقاومه
الاوكرانيه بهذه المنظومات الان المساله
بتختلف همم يعني اسلحه ثقيله الى حد كبير
حتى لو كان جزء منها اسلحه يعني ثقيله لكن
خفيفه تستطيع ان هي تتحرك في ميدان له
ظروفه مع تغير الاجواء الفصليه من وقت
الاخرون بالتالي هناك خوف طبعا بتصيره كل
القوه الغربيه من مساله المستخدم الاخير
همم فكره ان يتم نقل هذا السلاح الى
تنظيمات ارهابيه او ما الى ذلك طول الوقت
يعني هناك ضغط في هذا الش- لكن انا اتصور
انه ده كان المخوف فيه اكثر يبقى ليه
اسلحه الافراد او الاسلحه اللي كانت
المقاومه الاوكرانيه بتستخدمها بشكل اكبر
وهمم لكن بالنسبه لهذا النمط الجديد اللي
بتفرده حاله التسلل حاليا او خريطه التسلح
الحاليه انا اعتقد ان الوضع مختلف المساله
انه سيكون هناك او بالفعل بدا هناك تدريب
على هذه الاسلحه للقوات نظميه وايضا سوف
يكون هناك يعني نوع من انه يعني هذه
الاساحه سوف ترسل الى مواقع صحيح انه
التقديرات الامريكيه بتقول احنا ما نقدرش
نراقب اكثر من 10% من حركه التسلح بالنسبه
لهذه الاسلحه داخل اوكرانيا لانه زياده
المراقبه عن كده يتطلب بوجود قوات امريكيه
او شهرين امريكا على الصحه الاوكرانيه وده
هيكون عامل تهديد لكن المهم حاليا دلوقت
ان في حاله من التكيف مع المعطيات الحاليه
سواء بالنسبه لحاله التسلق او بالنسبه حتى
للمتغيرات المعركه مع الربيع يعني لو ااا
روسيا فكرت ان هي تطور بعد ما تنتهي مثلا
من معركه ضخمت لكيف او ما الى ذلك الموضوع
هيختلف لانه هيبقى فيه منظومات متعدده
المنظمات الدفاع القصيرات ما همم يكون من
اجراءات دائما نستفيد من وجودك معنا شكرا
جزيلا استاذ احمد علي بالبحث في وحده
دراسات الامنيه والعسكريه شكرا
اشارت صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه الى مشاركه
كبيره للمواطنين الفنلنديين في مواقع
الكترونيه تتيح كتابه رسائل وتوقيعات على
قذائف المدافع الاكرانيه المستخدمه في
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وذلك بمقابل
مبالغ ماليه تتراوح بين 200$ و500$ امريكي
تذهب هذه الاموال تعمل للقوات الاوكرانيه
اصوات المدافع الاوكرانيه المدعومه من
فنلندا في حربها مع روسيا ليست كافيه
للفنلنديين لابداء دعمهم في الصراع
الدائره
وسائلهم على قضاء في المدافع تسجل
استمراريه وتصميم لهذا الدعم منصه فنلنديه
غير ربحيه تدعس دوت كوم تعلن السماحه لدعم
القوات الاوكرانيه بالتوقيع وكتابه رسائل
على ذخائر الاوكرانيه ثم اعاده نشرها في
ما بعد
التوقيع مقابل الدعم المالي ما بين 200
دولار امريكي الى 500 قيمه لوضع اسماء
ورسائل الفلنديين على قضاء في المدفعيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ووفقا لصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه فان
المواقع الالكترونيه المشابهه والمتخصصه
بالتبرع لاوكرانيا جمعت مئات الالاف من
الدولارات منذ اطلاقها فيما تحظى فنلندا
من نصيب الاكبر من هذه التبرعات
قلق المواطنين الفنلنديين من ان تطال
بلادهم نيران الحرب الروسيه عكسته ارقام
اليها التايمز حيث دعى
58% من الفنلنديين الى رفع ميزانيه البلاد
العسكريه كما اعرب
85% عن قلقهم بشان تصعيد روسي المتزايد
تحرك الفلنديين بالتبرع والتوقيع على
القضاء في الاوكرانيه يتزامنوا مع
مواجهتهم ازمه طاقه فبعد ما اعتمدت فنلندا
على ثلث احتياجاتها من روسيا الان تقترب
من الرقم صفر الامر الذي يجعل تفسيرا
لمواجهه فرنديين للساقيه برسائل القذائف
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
رغم الانتعاض الصينيه تواصل الدول الغربيه
والماني الجزيره وخرج بعدها نواب
ليتوانيون لياكد تعرض بلادهم والمسافرين
فيها لكل محاولات كسر الاراده من جانب
بكين وتحديهم لكل هذا
الذي تتعرض له
ممثل للتهديد الذي تتعرض له بلادهم من
روسيا وصفين الاثنتين روسيا والصين بالجار
المستبد ليتوانيا
بعد ان سمحت بفتح مكتب تمثيلي تايوان على
اراضيها تحت اسم تايوان بدلا من تايبي
الصينيه وهو مصطلح تستخدمه دول اخرى لتجنب
غضب بكينا
تعول على الدعم الليتواني وطبعا الالماني
يقضي لتهديدات تين
[موسيقى]
قديم
الديمقراطيه والحريه اعتبارا من العام
المقبل سيتم تمديد الخدمه العسكريه
الالزاميه لتايوان الى عام واحد لتعزيز
قدرتنا الدفاعيه واظهار عزمنا على الدفاع
عن وطننا وحمايه الديمقراطيه نحن نتطلع
الى تايوان والمانيا والشركاء
الديمقراطيين الاخرين معا للحفاظ على
النظام الاقليمي والازدهار
كل هذه المنشدات تاتي بينما سيكون التعويل
الاول والاكثر اهميه لتايوان هو على
الولايات المتحده بطبيعه الحال خاصه ان
كان هناك اعتداء عسكري صينيه احدث
التقارير في هذا الاطار لمركز الدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والدوليه سي اس اي اس نفذ
محاكتا لغزو صيني لتايوان في 20 26 تشارك
فيها جيوش الصين واليابان وتايوان وامريكا
وكانت النتيجه
لكنها ستترك الجيش الامريكي المنتصر في
حاله شلل تماما كحاله القوه الصينيه
المهزومه خلص التقرير الى انه مع نهايه
الحرب ستغرق على الاقل حاملات طائرات
امريكيتان في قاع المحيط الهادئ وستكون
البحريه الصينيه الحديثه وهي الاكبر في
العالم في حاله من الفوضى ويرصد التقرير
مقتل حوالي ثلاثه الاف ومئتين جندي امريكي
في ثلاثه اسابيع من القتال اي ما يقرب من
نصف ما خسرته الولايات المتحده في عقدين
من القتال في العراق وافغانستان
فستخسر هي الاخرى 10,000 جندي وسيقع عشرات
الالاف من الجنود في الاسر
لكن الجانب الايجابي في الموضوع عن
الخبراء الذين اعتمد التقرير على ارائهم
استبعد غزوه صينيا شاملا للجزيره البالغ
عدد سكانها 24 مليون نسمه
الصريح
ان هذه العمليه ستؤدي على الفور ستؤدي الى
تعطيل الواردات والصادرات التي يعتمد
عليها الاقتصاد الصيني لبقائه وبالتالي قد
تتسبب في انهيار الاقتصاد الصيني في وقت
قصيره
ان الصين التي تعتمد على واردات الغذاء
والوقود لقياده محركها الاقتصادي ليس
لديها مجال كاف للمخاطره او حتى للمنوره
الحرب الشامله مستبعده والضغوط الاقتصاديه
الصينيه هي الاقرب الغاز الصيني لتايوان
قد يسقط الجزيره بالكامل في غضون ثلاثه
اشهر او اقل اذا لم تتدخل امريكا
فان الغزوه الصيني لن ينجح
وبلسمنه سيكون باهظا على الجميع
[موسيقى]
في تطور اللافت بعد التقارب التركيه
الاسرائيليه بدات السلطات التركيه في
تشديد القيود على تحركات قياده حماس على
اراضيها
ربط هذا التطور بعمليه التطبيع التي افضت
مؤخرا لعمليه تبادل السفراء بينما يرى
اخرون انها ترتبط ايضا بالانتخابات
القادمه
رياح السياسه التركيه تهب بعيدا عن حركه
حماس رياح تسريب علاقات انقره معتل ابيب
في مجرى بعيد عن اهوى الحركه زياره رئيس
الاسرائيلي لانقره في مارس الماضي حملت
معها مطالبه لتركيا بابعاد حماس وقادتها
عن اراضيها طلبات اسرائيل لم تلقى استجابه
تركيه حينها لكن تقارير افادت بان السلطات
التركيه بدات مؤخرا في تجديد القيود على
تحركات قيادات حماس باراضيها انقل الى حتى
هذه اللحظه ما زالت ترفض هذه الضغوط
الاسرائيليه ولكنها تقوم بزاويه اخرى
بالتضيق وتقييد حركه همم القيادات
القادمين من الخارج داخل الى داخل تركيا
وحتى المقيمين من عناصر القيادات حماس
وهنا في الداخل عده تقارير اكدت ان انقره
بدات بالحد من ظهور قاده في تركيا وعدم
السماح لقيادات من الصف الاول او اقل
بالمجيء الى تركيا بقصد الاقامه انما
بزيارات قصيره
للمشاركه في مؤتمرات او اجتماعات ويرى
متابعون ان سياسه حكومه حزب العداله
والتنميه الجديده تجاه حماس لا ترتبط فقط
بعمليه التطبيع لكن ايضا باهم استحقاق
داخلي هذا العام الا وهو الانتخابات
في هذا الموضوع الانتخابات تقترب لذلك
الحكومه استداره الخلف في سياسته الخارجيه
وتحاول اعطاء رسائل من اجل ارساء السلامه
واقامه علاقات جديده وتركز تركيا على
شخصيات لها ارتباط عسكري بحماس حيث ذكرت
وسائل اعلام ان السلطات ابعدت 10 اشخاص
قبل فتره ما ترك عناصر الحركه في حاله قلق
صعوبه منح الاقامات لعدد كبير منهم لا شك
ان علاقه تركيا بحماس لن تكون كما كانت
عليه قبل تطويع العلاقات مع تل ابيب صحيح
ان انقر لن تستجب لمطالب الاسرائيليين
بالتخلي الكامل عن حماس لكن الساحه
التركيه لن تعود من الان فصاعدا مجال
الرحبا لقاده الحركه وفق ما يراه كثير
زيدان زينجو العربيه اسطنبول
وتتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 بعد قليل
المانيا توصل مشروعها الجدلي الانتزاع
الفحم من منجب غرب البلاد لكن عليها اولا
انتزاع البشر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وثائقي سريه وجدت في
مكتب الرئيس الامريكي الحالي في مركزه
للدراسات تعود الى الفتره التي تسلم فيها
منصبه نائب الرئيس قد تعرضه للمساءله
بالتشجيع من جمهوريه مجلس النواب
تتعلق باوكرانيا وايران لكن بين حالتي
وثائق ترامب ووث كثير من الاختلافات اولها
ان من ابلغ عن الوثائق في حاله بايدن هم
موظفون لديهم التفاصيل مع ناديه
في هذا المبنى في الطابق السادس عثر على
وثائق التقريبا 10 صنفت بانها وثائق سريه
تابعه للرئيس بيض عندما كان يشغل منصب
نائبا رئيس طبعا هذا سبب احراج كبير للبيت
الابيض لانه اتهم بالزواجيه المعايير
بالمقارنه مما حدث مع الرئيس ترامب الذي
حقق الاف بي اي في الوثائق التي وجدت في
مره لارجو لكن البعض يقول بانه لا مقارنه
اولا البيت الابيض اعرب عن تعاونه مع طبعا
مكتب التحقيق الفيدرالي وقال بانه يريد ان
يعيد كل هذه الوثائق الى الارشيف الوطني
وان هذه الوثائق لا تحمل مثلا اسرار نوويه
او غيرها لكن بغض النظر رئيس مجلس النواب
كيف مقاسي قال بان الامر مقلق للغايه وهذا
طبعا سيسبب احراج كبير للبيت الابيض وقد
يؤثر على مستقبل الرئيس السياسي
تبقى معنا ناديه البلبيسي مراسله العربيه
من واشنطن اهلا بك معنا ناديه هل من جديد
بعد اعدادك لهذا التقرير وهل هناك ما يشرب
التالي بانه هذه قضيه قد تستغل من
الجمهوريين وقد تكبر
اهلا بك طاهر طبعا انا لا ازال اقف امام
هذا المبنى في السابق السادس كانت لدينا
بعض الصور الحصريه من شخص كان يعمل فيه
قال بان محامي الرئيس عثروا على هذه
الوثائق عندما كانوا يقومون باغلاق هذا
المكتب وهو قريب على فكره من كافه
عندما كان همم الرئيس يعمل به لكن هذه
الوثائق كانت في الفتره التي عمل فيها بيض
النائب الرئيس سنه 2013 2016 قالوا ليا
هذا يعتمد على وزاره العدل طبعا ماري جارل
وهو وزير العدل موجود مع الرئيس
المكسيك موقف محرج نوعا ما لكنه حول هذه
القضيه لمده عيانه الرئيس ترامب وحتى
بالتحيز للبيت الابيض
وطبعا وقد البيت الابيض حتى الان لم يعلن
موقف رسمي لكن التسريبات تقول انه كما
ذكرت هناك تعاون لم يكن مطلوب كان هناك
خاصه ايضا تتعلق بالرئيس في هذا الصندوق
ليس فقط عن وثائق سريه لكن ايضا عن همم
جنازه ابن الرئيس
ومعلومات سريه عفوا معلومات خاصه اخرى تم
نقلها الى الاس بي اي لكن بدون ان الشرك
في جو مشحون سياسيا وحزبيا سيكون هناك
مساءله من الجمهوريه فقط ناديه تحدثت منذ
قليل بتقريرك عن اوجه الاختلاف بين
الوثائق المسربه لترامب وبايدر ومن سرب
هذه الوفاء فعليا مسار التحقيق بالقديتين
هل سيكون هو نفسه
لا سيكون مختلف تمام لانه كما تعرفين كان
هناك اقتحام لمنزل الرئيس عفوا ترامب في
مره لارجو وتم مصادره عدد كبير من
الصناديق التي تحوي على 60 وثيقه سريه و16
وثيقه وثيقه كانت مصنفه بانها غايه في
السريه عاده عن ذلك تحقيق فعل بدا ضد
الرئيس
واتهم بانه يعرقل العداله بانه لم يسلم
هذه الاوراق الوثائق السوريه عندما طلب
منه الى الارشيف الوطني العكس هنا بانه
هذه الوثائق لا تتعد 10 على الاقل حتى
الان لا نعرف اذا كان هناك تطورات بعد ذلك
يعني منذ هذا التقرير التي لعبته قبل قليل
كان هناك حديث لسيانين على ان بعض هذه
الوثائق تضم معلومات عن اوكرانيا عن ايران
عن المملكه المتحده همم ربما هي معلومات
تتعلق بالسياسه الخارجيه قدمت بعيدا عندما
كان نائب الرئيس ساكن بشكل عام همم دون ان
شك الحلتين مختلفتين تماما وهناك تعاون
بشكل وثيق يعني مجرد ما اكتشف محامي بيض
بان هناك هذه الوثائق التي صنفت بالسريه
همم سلمت الى الارشيف الوطني لكن بشكل عام
اعتقد بانه سيدتهم مره اخرى همم بازدواجيه
المعايير كما ذكرت وسيكون هناك مساءله
وقبل قليل على فكره رئيس لجنه الاستخبارات
الجمهوري في هذه اللجنه طلب من رئيسه
الاستخبارات ان تقوم همم ما يسمى بتقييم
الخطر بسبب هذه الوثائق سنرى لاحقا اذا
كان هناك تداعيات لكنها ستطال بيض من دون
ان شك في الجو مشكون سياسيه
دائما شكرا جزيلا لك مراسله العربيه
اذا القوات المواليه بهذا الخبر العاجل
لروسيا في دونات تعلن السيطره الكامله على
وسط بلده سوليت بعد اشهر من الترقب
تخللتها حمله دعائيه متواصله طرحت مذكرات
الامير هاري سبير او البديل في اسواق
المملكه المتحده وقالت وسائل اعلام
بريطانيه ان مذكرات الامير هاري سجلت اعلى
مبيعات لمذكرات من نوعها في التاريخ
البريطاني
الله
غالبيه
من وقت الى اخر يدخلوا احد بينهم لا
يستحقوا مكانته لكن هذا لا يعني ان اعضاء
العائله الاخرين غير جديرين بالاحترام يجب
ان نتجاهل هاري
الكتاب ولا اعتقد انه من الامور التي نريد
ان نكتب او نتحدث عنها
وصل الى هذه المرحله هذا سيئون له
احبكم حبايبي
للعائله الملكيه امر سيء يجب ان يبقى ذلك
امرا خاصا وخلف الابواب المغلقه اعتقد انه
سيؤدي الى مزيد من الدعم للعائله الملكيه
لكن هاري سيخسر ذلك الدعم الناس تنظر اليه
على انه طعنهم في الظهر
سيثير ضجه رغم اننا اطلعنا على افضل ما
فيه من خلال تسريبات الصحافه وما قاله
هاري مؤخرا للتمهيد للكتاب لا اعتقد شخصيا
انني ساجد شيئا جديدا فيه لكنني متاكده
انك اذا كنت مؤيدا للعائله اولهاري ستجد
ضالتك فيه
هكذا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختام ملفات
العربيه 360